en este vídeo quiero hacer algunos
ejemplos observando distribuciones y en
particular diferentes características en
distribuciones como agrupamientos
agujeros y picos entonces bueno aquí
veremos algunos ejemplos muy bien así
que dice cuál de las siguientes son
descripciones exactas de la distribución
de abajo elige todas las opciones
correctas bueno la primera opción dice
la distribución tiene un pico en 12
pesos por hora
veamos si esto es cierto aquí tenemos
esta gráfica de puntos dice salario por
hora de cada empleado en cual inc y
bueno aquí se representan los pesos por
hora entonces dice la distribución tiene
un pico en 12 pesos por ahora veamos
aquí está 10 11 12 y en efecto vemos que
si hay un pico en 12 pesos por hora así
que esa es una de las opciones correctas
ahora la siguiente opción dice la
distribución tiene un valor atípico un
valor atípico es un valor mucho mayor o
mucho menor
mientras que los otros valores tienen
cierto agrupamiento entonces por ejemplo
aquí podemos ver que hay un que hay un
agrupamiento de los valores entre 8
pesos por hora y 18 pesos por hora pero
aquí en 28 vemos que hay un valor
atípico este valor queda separado del
resto es mucho mayor al resto
entonces la distribución si tiene un
valor atípico muy bien entonces vemos si
sacamos de una respuesta perfecto
hagamos otros ejercicios muy bien vamos
con este siguiente ejemplo dice cuáles
de las siguientes son descripciones
exactas de la distribución de abajo
elige todas las opciones correctas
la primera opción dice la distribución
tiene un pico de 70 a 80 mil pesos muy
bien veamos veamos qué nos dice la
distribución entonces aquí tenemos una
gráfica de barras salario de cada
empleado de trin cels vemos el número de
empleados y los miles de pesos
así que queremos ver si la distribución
tiene un pico de 70 a 80 mil pesos
aquí están 70 y 80 mil pesos pero vemos
que no de hecho el pico estaría entre 50
y 60 mil pesos así que la distribución
no tiene un pico de 70 a 80 mil pesos
esa no es una opción la siguiente opción
dice la distribución tiene un
agrupamiento de 0 a 30 mil pesos
veamos si esto es cierto
en efecto podemos ver aquí que tenemos
un agrupamiento de 0 a 30 mil pesos de
hecho tenemos otro agrupamiento de 40 a
100 mil pesos así que esa es una de las
opciones correctas entonces vamos a
elegir esta opción y vemos si tenemos la
respuesta correcta perfecto hagamos otro
ejercicio entonces bueno veamos este
ejemplo cuáles de las siguientes son
descripciones exactas de la distribución
de abajo elige todas las opciones
correctas
la primera opción dice la distribución
tiene un agrupamiento de 33 o 37 millas
por galón muy bien veamos si eso es
verdad aquí tenemos esta gráfica de
puntos dice rendimiento de la gasolina
de cada automóvil de motor es mi ley
y vemos que aquí se nos dice las millas
por galón entonces queremos ver si la
distribución tiene un agrupamiento de 33
a 37 millas por galón
aquí está 33 y 37 millas y vemos que
aquí no hay ningún agrupamiento de hecho
hay agrupamientos entre 20 millas y 32
millas por galón y también hay otro
agrupamiento entre 38 millas por galón y
42 millas por galón así que esta no es
una opción la siguiente opción dice la
distribución tiene un agujero de 38 a 42
millas por galón veamos aquí está a 38 y
aquí está a 42 millas por galón no no
tiene un agujero en agujero hay entre 33
a 37 millas aquí tenemos un agrupamiento
entonces tampoco es una de las opciones
correctas así que en este caso ninguna
de las anteriores sería la opción
correcta
hagamos otro ejercicio este ejercicio
dice cuál de las siguientes son
descripciones exactas de la distribución
de abajo elige todas las opciones
correctas y la primera opción dice la
distribución tiene un valor atípico
veamos si esto es cierto entonces aquí
tenemos esta distribución tenemos esta
gráfica de barras que representa los
estados visitados por cada piloto de
aerolíneas motor tenemos aquí el número
de pilotos y el número de estados que
visitaron entonces podemos ver aquí que
hubo un piloto que visitó entre 0 y 4
estados hubo aproximadamente dos pilotos
que visitaron entre 20 y 24 estados hubo
cinco que visitaron entre 25 y 29
estados hubo seis que visitaron entre 30
y 34 estados hubo ocho que visitaron
entre 35 y 39 estados hubo 12 que
visitaron entre 40 y 44 estados y hubo
10 que visitaron entre 45 y 49 estados
entonces queremos ver si hay un valor
atípico en efecto solamente hubo un
piloto que visitó entre cero y cuatro
estados acá podemos ver un agrupamiento
pero este valor queda totalmente aislado
del resto entonces este es un valor
atípico recuerda que un valor atípico es
un valor mucho mayor o mucho menor que
el resto mientras que el resto está en
un agrupamiento entonces en este caso
tenemos este valor atípico que es mucho
menor que el resto o también podrías
verlo como un valor que está mucho más a
la izquierda o mucho más a la derecha un
valor aislado podemos decir entonces
este es un valor atípico así que una de
las respuestas correctas es la
distribución tiene un valor atípico en
efecto ahora la distribución tiene un
agujero de 20 a 29 estados
veamos si esto es cierto
bien entonces queremos ver si hay un
agujero entre 20 y 29 estados no no lo
hay hay un agujero entre 5 y 19 estados
pero aquí no hay un agujero así que esa
no es una opción correcta entonces la
única opción correcta es que la
distribución tiene un valor atípico y
ninguna de las anteriores bueno esa no
es una una de las opciones correctas y
bueno
perfecto